and welcome to this video playing CSIS
from Finland and that's a regular
opponent I really didn t play for the
other games somehow i have this
recollection okay so kind of pretty rare
linea in them the NIMS oh and needs to
sharply II 598 and then possibly okay
that's a surprising choice opening up my
CH bishop so began wonder yeah probably
still here keeping the the bishop open
now nf6 oh yeah I guess f6 looks good
yeah one problem that white has is that
he has some some weak squares really the
light squares in particular I want
Knight to c4 with 97 there might be 6
what it cannot really not sure that he
can support this maybe he can yeah e 6 9
p-6 f 596 bishop age three it looks very
weird
okay let's try that that's interesting
really yeah of course very quickly plate
it's super committal but will be played
instantaneously okay this is very very
sharp now let's let's start with with
this opening the a file I mean you
probably place ruka the rook in any case
he doesn't okay so let's let's enter
here he's got this porn on his six
that's clear but otherwise the position
is full of holes might be too also
possible now and then take here maybe
Quincy 193 is very simple aunty I can
take be four so what's the idea cannot
recapture and must take them and now
it's interesting i can take or play
Knights afore i can also take on a three
it's not totally crazy but ok let's
let's take here first this is easier
probably right not be five now or night
see I Bishop f5 is actually quite nice
well he's winning the Queen but he is
only spent one minute ten for the game
song nice nice job yeah I don't
understand wine and complicated
unconventional positions you should move
immediately but ok it's just just my
point of view I'm not sure that 97 is
really great I mean here I can also play
let's say Bishop 222 f5 or something
White has made very very little piece
moves it's not really developed well and
I have this this idea I think black is
ok here but it shouldn't be a big
advantage or something it's maybe
unclear or something like that e 6 now
debatable maybe it's good for white but
I thought it was interesting to play
this when g for the bishop h3 is an
interesting alternative because who the
bishop certainly does not belong on g2
by just looking at porn murcia d5 c6 and
maybe bishop a tree makes sense in any
case but ok he played this and now this
very quickly yeah the interesting very
interesting position and i went here
oops sorry i went to see form I'm better
developed
interesting position yeah this is this
is probably not very good um what should
he do actually yeah I played here the
computer gives a before with the with
the win actually of course this this
move order is much much better much
better I forgot that that my age rook is
basically well rook e8 yeah I mean the
queen is not a text I simply simply
forgot about this and this this
basically means that if you look at this
this is forced now check black wins
Hanks Hanks 93r white is totally falling
apart and this wasn't even good here
Quincy to a be four years of Knight
takes d5 now this desperado that's very
good for white yeah that's very good for
my g5 now is hanging jared is winning
here almost it looks very bad okay but
you played this as you know in one
second takes on c3 and this in three
seconds blundered the Queen so Knight c3
is probably what needs to be done with
the night c forum maybe you must move
the Queen this is not not really great
so it probably must do this yeah and
then this is a totally unclear position
at least I have no idea what's going on
this phone is say is really a problem
really is maybe this Queen d6 and try
take the pawn tricky but okay this was
just the Queen okay thanks for watching